uh what what do you think here about her
just
remarkable fall from grace it's really
been spectacular and the impact on us
domestically
thanks so much tammy look um it's
frightening because this is a woman the
vice president who is a heartbeat away
from the presidency and the president
himself is 79 years old so
you want your vice president to be ready
to lead she can't even lead her own
office i mean these reports have been
coming in a steady drum beat
for months actually and in fact even
before
she became vice president um during her
own campaign where she bottomed out you
know with a couple of percent popularity
i mean just woeful um there was talk
then that her office was in disarray and
now it seems that you know i mean
to be described as a bully yeah uh soul
destroying criticism this is
from people who are putting their names
to it
this is something
suspected previously that there was
leaking coming from
the white house
she's she's obviously not someone who
plays very well with others
what's remarkable is the opportunity
that she has if the president in fact is
uh not competent this is an opportunity
for a vice president to deliver
to be to be the one who shines and even
to enjoy the moment of being this first
woman vice president and to really be
nice to people do you think her staff is
leaving because they want to leave or
because she has wanted them to leave
no i think it's because she's just
impossible to work for a as you say all
she really has to do is be pleasant and
popular and she can't manage to do that
she seems to have a real chip on her
shoulder
i mean look the problem is that she
really was elevated above her ability
she was chosen by joe biden not because
of her quality of her work or her
intellect it was because she was a woman
and she was a woman of color and that
puts her in a bad position and it puts
america in a terrible position it does
in addition to all of the women of color
who are perfectly capable where the
messaging is is that oh this is what
happens as a woman who wants women in
the white house it it hurts and it we
have a duty to make sure the competent
are elevated because there are plenty
of those so thank you